[Musique]
françois bayrou bonjourbonjour haut
commissaire au plan maire de pau
président du modem nous avons parlé
entre autres énergies démographie mais
je voudrais commencer avec la politique
faut-il aujourd'hui j'ai une question
toute simple est il aujourd'hui pour
être écouté par les fons et tenir des
propos violents défendre des idées
extrêmes et proposer des solutions
radicales
c'est plus facile d'être entendus ou
d'être de choquer ou deux sont réalisés
de surfer sur
des sentiments qui sont des sentiments
plus noir
c'est plus facile mais
l'intérêt
des pères des mères de famille l'intérêt
des jeunes l'intérêt du bruit oui c'est
au contraire de refuser d'aller dans
cette sous ce qu'on appelle des
radicalités les radicalité qu'est ce que
c'est c'est des extrémismes de tous les
bords le l'idée que que c'est en
choquant en allant agité
les vieilles les vieilles passions
dangereuses du pays en allant versé de
l'essence sur sur le feu
c'est plus facile mais ceci est un
abandon des responsabilités un abandon
de responsabilité le plus radical c'est
eric zemmour je vais pas passer ne vous
inquiétez pas je vais pas passer cette
cette interview sur eric zemmour
néanmoins le plus radical c'est eric
zemmour il brandit la menace du grand
emplacement une idée récurrente de
l'extrême droite depuis le 19e siècle
est ce qu'il nous entraîne vers ce que
nous appellerions une guerre de
civilisation
ya
deux aspects oui de la campagne qu'il
mène oui le premier aspect c'est agiter
ce ce fonds qui font des êtres humains
depuis longtemps qui consiste à
cibler celui qui ne vous ressemble pas
en disant on n'a rien à faire avec lui
qu'il retourne chez lui
et c'est toute cette affaire un sens et
des prénoms où il c'est à dire l'idée
que
le en france ne serait autorisé qu'une
liste de prénoms français
ce qui veut dire évidemment que l'on
jette dans les cours de récréation des
enfants les uns contre les autres
enfants dans la qui c'est celui là il
n'est pas de chez nous or le plus
précieux d'un pays c'est que à l'école
maternelle à l'école primaire celui qui
est assis à côté de vous dans la classe
c'est votre petit frère votre petite
soeur et on lui prend la main parce
qu'il est comme chez nous vous voyez que
pour moi la cour de récréation c'est en
fait le creuset du pays et l'idée que
celui là où le père dessus de celui là
ou de celle là n'est pas du pays c'est
une idée qui entraîne à la cruauté dans
la cour de récréation est donc cette
idée là pour moi est une idée
insupportable
il ya une deuxième chose c'est que ea va
chercher dans l'histoire de la france ce
qu'il y a de plus malsain de plus
honteux de plus ignominieux
pour le défendre par exemple bip et un
bon il a livré des juifs étrangers
s'étaient pas des juifs français
quatre mille enfants
de 2 3 4 ans ont été livrés enfermés
dans des camps et puis chargé avec leurs
parents dans dix vingt ou ou sans leurs
parents dans des wagons à bestiaux pour
allait être brûlé en allemagne et que
ceux-ci et qu'on n'ose faire la
différence ou qu'on n'ose à nouveau en
france faire la différence entre le
petit garçon ou la petite fille juifs
fils de nez en france fils de parents
étrangers et
les enfants qui avaient simplement une
carte d'identité sais
c'est pas si vous pouvez ressentir ça je
suis sûr que je sais je sais qu'il ya
bouleverse sam oui et ça me bouleverse
et il est normal que ça le fasse et que
ces gens-là aux s'appelait conservateurs
ou essaie de capter le mot conservateurs
alors que ça n'est pas un saint épain
conserver ce que nous avons de mieux
dans le pays c'est trahir ce que nous
avons de mieux dans le pays c'est une
trahison de la france c'est une trahison
de de ce qui nous fait vivre ensemble de
savez que nous avons construit le pays
c'est une tradition
c'est une trahison de marie curie
celle qui a
[Musique]
inventé ces ou découvert ces lois de
physique sur les rayonnements alors il
est dans son livre il est très dur avec
vous ai dit bayrou ce bon judas béarnais
est un machiavel de cour d'école qui
monte des coups tordus de sous
préfecture j'ai lu ça dans son livre
vous l'avez lu peut-être je peux aussi
vous avez lu son livre enfin bon bon il
est en train sur le terrain politique
est ce qu'il est en train de diviser les
républicains quand j'entends christian
jacob vous entendez christian jacob dire
il n'est pas d'extrême droite il n'est
pas raciste le président des
républicains que lui répondez vous
d'abord j'ai
je n'ai pas de débat avec jacob se débat
avec la réalité si le président de la
droite oui dit de gouvernement en france
d'une certaine manière
à valise ou lave l'auteur de ces propos
de delà de la réalité de de la honte
qu'il porte
alors il trahit lui-même l'héritage
parce que je croyais vaguement que
ce parti des républicains que je connais
bien et dont je connais beaucoup de
membres que j'ai steen on n'a pas les
mêmes idées toujours mais que j'ai steen
je croyais que ce parti était vaguement
gaulliste
et
prétendre devant ceux qui se disent
héritier du général de gaulle que pétain
c'était la france que le pépin de la
collaboration et de la livraison des
juifs
c'était la france alors ya là quelque
chose qui est simplement un crachat la
visage de l'histoire au visage de
l'histoire un crachat à l'heure à leur
héritage à leur identité
et je suis absolument certain qu'à
l'intérieur même du mouvement il ya des
gens qui vont dire mais ça va pas dans
quelles dérives se meut nous entraîner
et vous voyez bien tout ça pourquoi
vous n'allez pas me dire que zemmour est
passionné par le destin historique de
l'image du maréchal pétain ce pas ça du
tout le sujet le sujet c'est qui se sert
de ça pour faire des signes à ce qu'il
ya de plus
de plus de
fermentation la plus dangereuse dans
ceux qui depuis très longtemps
dans le monde de la démocratie française
essaie de faire glisser les choses vers
l'inacceptable françois bayrou est ce
que vous allez créer un grand parti
démocrate à la française gérant n'en
parle où j'espère que oui avant la fin
de l'année avant la fin de l'année parce
qu'autrement ça ne fera pas que vous
appelleriez comment ah ben on verra
pas trouvé le nom
m'arrive d'avoir des idées de ne pas les
dire au micro à bourdin a bon oui c'est
un ici on dit les choses et bg les
choses françois il m'avait posé la
question j'ai ben oui j'espère qu'on va
y arriver mais donc vous allez créer un
grand parti démocrate à la française en
réunissant le modem et la république en
marche c'est l'objectif entre autres
entre autres entre autres donc
rassembler ces deux mouvements
politiques parce que ce sont les deux
mouvements fondateur de laventure de
2017 et qu'
ils n'ont pas entre eux de différences
de vision ils ont des différences
d'histoire et d'organisation oui un
substantiel mais le sueur sur ce qu'il
croit
c'est essentiel en politique ce qu'on
croit et sur ce qu'ils veulent c'est
aussi important alors moi je ne vois pas
de différence substantielle entre eux
bien avant la fin de l'année donc ce
grand parti démocrate vous pourriez
prendre la tête de ce parti
oui ou non oui non enfin blanche mais ça
n'a aucun intérêt et ma conviction c'est
que si on veut réunir alors il faut
qu'il y ait des responsabilités
partagées bon mais vous n'êtes pas seuls
à vouloir créer un grand parti et dort
philippe lui aussi va annoncer la
création de son parti ou de son
rassemblement le 9 octobre il va
soutenir emmanuel macron comme vous en
2022 est ce qu'il est en train de
préparer sa candidature présidentielle à
2027 je pense que quelqu'un qui en 2021
aurait comme projet passant par-dessus
l'élection présidentielle de monter une
structure pour 2027 c'est qu'il ne
connaîtrait pas la politique et je ne
soupçonne pas edouard philippe dans les
seniors ça
peut-être c'est ça dans un coin de sa
tête ou de la tête de ses amis mais may
à bout d'une panne du genre vous n'étiez
pas dû vous avez trop d'expérience en
politique on gérait un peu d'expérience
wii est donc inattendu et donc je vais
je vais vous
si on fait aussi on entre dans cette
construction dans l'édification d'un
mouvement sérieux faut le faire pour des
générations pas pour une élection encore
moins faut-il le faire en pensant à une
autre élection que celle qui vient est
donc pour moi ce ceci est totalement
écartée de ma pensée
ce qui est dans ma pensée c'est bâtir
quelque chose dans lesquelles les jeunes
les français les citoyens le ceux qui
sont aujourd'hui désabusé de la
politique puisse se reconnaître leur
espoir où leurs rêves et qu'ils
s'engagent pour cela hier soir vous avez
dîner à l'elysée avec lui avec d'autres
autour de la table vous n'avez pas parlé
de ça j'imagine va vous me
direz rien
vous savez bien géré j'ai un problème à
bord médical que je suis obligé de vous
avez mâtina cette antenne pas matinale
une amnésie récurrentes une amnésie
reker chaque fois oui que je que je
franchi le seuil de l'elysée par exemple
où je participe à des réunions comme ça
le lendemain et le surlendemain a
fortiori je ne sais plus et ben c'est
alors françois bayrou mais rassurez-vous
vous allez trouver beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui vous raconteront
qui vont raconter ça s'est passé hier
soir rue réforme des retraites réforme
des retraites edouard philippe veut une
réforme des retraites il le dit dans une
interwiew
forte interview il dit il faut prolonger
l'âge de départ 65 66 et même 67 ans est
ce qu'il y aura une réforme des
retraites relancer avant la
présidentielle de 2000 22 la réforme des
retraites sera au coeur de la campagne
de l'élection présidentielle c'est un
des sujets pas le seul qui sera au coeur
de l'élection oui de la campagne de
l'élection présidentielle moi je crois
qui a des idées qu'on n'a pas encore
exploré et si je peux je ferai tout ce
que je peux pour que ces idées
apparaissent dans le débat
pour l'instant on fait uniquement des
divisions le oui la charge des pensions
divisé
et je crois qu'on peut aller un peu plus
loin dans la réflexion vous savez que
j'avais depuis très longtemps plaidé
pour la retraite par points ça a été
pas très bien mener sa part edouard fait
les seuls noms enfin 90 gouvernement ça
mais moi non mais vous vous dites ça
parce que vous vous aimez la polémique
vous aimez que les gimmicks c'est votre
boulot sobaru l'eau pour faire de
l'audience aujourd'hui il y a une
voiture qui est pilotée par emmanuel
macron sur le siège du passager avant
droit qui est assis et dort filet pour
françois bayrou écoutez franchement si
vous imaginez vous s'agit uniquement du
de mayol et d'un siège c'est que vous
comprenez pas très bien la connais bien
mais j'ai juste un joli tic c'est une
affaire d'hommes d'affaires de deux
éléments le premier c'est le leadership
qui a honte inculte et de porter des
idées et de les faire entendre vous et
le deuxième cette affaire deux
communautés d'equipe d'histoires de gens
qui se sont choisi depuis longtemps et
qui pense qu'ensemble ils vont pouvoir y
arriver et c'est pas comme vous voyez
une bagnole avec un siège maida alors
d'accord d'accord mais est-ce que
emmanuel macron un soupçon de doute
concernant la fiabilité des doigts
philippe selon vous voudrez pas non ne
croyez pas bon un mot encore sur ce
qu'ils proposent après je vais passer au
nucléaire et à l'énergie un mot sur ce
qu'ils proposent encore ils vont le
revenu pour les jeunes hauts revenus
engagement il n'ya pas très favorable et
de quoi parle-t-il donc bien il parle de
deux
des dates de delà des futures élections
de la dette il dit que c'est une
question fondamentale la dette bossi
c'est à dire j'ai plaidé pendant 20 ans
pour que ça devait d'une question
fondamentale est ce que je peux vous
dire sur la dette ou chose oui
vous savez que j'ai fait un rapport au
plan sur la dette justement sur la dette
de guerre que représente le coc vide et
sur le plan marshall dont on avait
besoin pourquoi
parce que ça n'est pas la même je me
suis battu comme un chien dans au début
des années 2000 sur la dette pourquoi
parce que les taux d'intérêt étaient à 4
ou 5 % par an alors que la croissance
était à un pour cent si vous avez si
vous emprunter à des taux aussi oh oui
alors que la croissance est si basse
alors tout d'un coup le poids de la
dette augmente sans interruption si
comme aujourd'hui vous empruntez à 0% et
que vous trouvez une croissance qui est
à des deux cette année six l'année
prochaine 4 % alors cette date là elle
est justifiée à condition de l'utiliser
à de l'investissement et pas à la
gaspiller est-ce que rina se reprend
mais je la comprends mais j'ai quand
jolie edouard philippe j'en termine avec
lui nous continuons à danser au dessus
d'un voile qu'en dit il est-ce que nous
continue à danser au dessus d'un volcan
il a été chef du gouvernement fait je
suis certain tout le monde ressent la
nécessité d'une solidarité minimale dans
les moments nous sommes non vous avez
donc des doutes non je n'ai pas de doute
vous voudriez le faire dans le sac et ce
n'est pas mon intention alors les prix
de l'énergie et françois bayrou les
primes énergie grimpe montrent que va
annoncer le 1er ce qu'est la possibilité
je ne sais pas moi une prime une prime
pour les plus modestes
une baisse des taxes un gel du prix du
gaz de l'électricité c'est possible je
ne crois pas que ce soit possible parce
que comme votre journaliste très bien
expliqué il ya eu une hutte oui le prix
du gaz ça n'est pas le gouvernement qui
fixe oui oui c'est le prix du gaz sur le
marché de l'énergie mondiale oui mais
est il normal rampe et de la tva sur
le ce que perçoit l'état sur les
taxations c'est à dire vous mon taxe sur
la taxe
vous allez on va attendre ce que le
premier ministre va dire moi je pense
que sans fin ce qu'on dit dans les
journaux que vous lisez autant que moi
c'est on va aider les ménages les plus
faibles pour faire face à ces
augmentations qui sont en effet lourde
bon et donc mais la vraie question
jamais y venir c'est le clown a dû de la
substitution est ce qu'on peut à la
place du carburant des voitures est ce
qu'on peut trouver
de l'énergie moins cher et sans
émissions de gaz à effet de serre parce
que tout ça est à replacer dans la
question planétaire
du climat et de l'atmosphère qui est de
plus en plus chargées en co2 gaz
carbonique comme on l'a appris à l'école
la vraie question c'est celle là donc il
faut développer encourager le nucléaire
donc je vais je vais le dire comme je
crois il faut le dire si on veut aller
vers de l'énergie
qu'ils soient sans émissions de gaz à
effet de serre il ya deux choses à faire
le renouvelable mais il est intermittent
il ya du soleil opel soleil a du vent
n'y a pas de vent il ya de l'eau dans
les cours d'eau il n'y en a pas et une
énergie pilotable est la seule qui
existe sans émissions de gaz à effet de
serre c'est le nucléaire donc urgent à
se construire sans cesse
et vous avez compris le gaz oui c'est
pas français c'est pas chez nous il faut
durcir ont tous déjà rire de nouvelles
centrales il faut avoir un programme qui
permette de prendre le relais des
centrales existantes
sans danger en maîtrisant loyal et le
complètement le nucléaire et son avenir
et tous les pays du monde sont
aujourd'hui en train d'y réfléchir et
nous avons la chance incroyable grâce
aux générations précédentes d'être parmi
les pays du monde qui maîtrise le mieux
cette technologie là et donc le
qu'on ne regarde pas ce en face c'est un
programme à 30 ans si on prend pas les
décisions dans les deux années qui
viennent on va se trouver devant une
rupture une falaise disent les
spécialistes qui est épouvantable
le
l'électricité nucléaire moment où on
veut tout électrifier les voitures les
chauffages pour qu'il n'y ait plus de
gaz de charbon de pétrole utilisé pour
notre vie quotidienne cette
électrification général impose qu'on
produise de l'électricité au cool ou
moins cher et avec les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre les plus basses et il
n'y a que la maîtrise de la production
nucléaire de l'électricité qui puisse
faire ça j'ai une dernière question
françois bayrou à propos de démographie
est ce que il faut plus d'immigrés en
france pour assurer un équilibre
démographique
non non ça dépend de la dynamique
de nos concitoyens de d'errance et
encourager les politiques familiales
absolument c'est vital
pourquoi parce que si vous essayez
l'allemagne a essayé de le faire avec de
très grandes difficultés ils ont décidé
un jour commune avait plus d'enfants il
ya très peu pour l'année de faire entrer
un milieu merkel un million de millions
de personnes et d'hommes en allemagne
sap a changé la courbe démographique
et deuxièmement ça crée des
perturbations culturel le sentiment que
nous n'assurerons plus nous mêmes notre
avenir au travers des enfants que nous
allons mettre au monde et que donc il
faut aller chercher ailleurs la
ressource qui nous permet simplement de
survivre de travail et de payer des
cotisations de fer que le pays reste
vivant c'est la raison pour laquelle la
question de la
dynamique des familles du choix que qui
est tellement mystérieux parce que c'est
une question pour la nation mais c'est
chaque femme d'abord et chaque homme
chaque mère et père de famille qui
décide pour lui même or ça ne se fait
que si la confiance revient et c'est
pourquoi la question de la confiance est
évidemment celle des échéances ce
crucial qui nous attendent merci
françois bayrou d'être venu nous voir ce
matin sur rmc et bfm tv